you guys want to play spin the mailbox
no yes get the sucker in space all right
now let's keep going let's keep going
I'm gonna I'm gonna get my tool back out
I think I can see on the rocket stick
with the big thrusters and turn the
force way the hell up yeah we need to
get some angular force going on here so
[Applause]
I gotta get under it this thing is
already shaking and making me feel
nauseous I know well hang on I need to
raise you up so we need to get to the
bottom s oh god hold Sal you're gonna be
just fine I believe you fine just hang
on and let me get the big one back out
then very very nice go hang on
[Applause]
[Music]
I gotta try that I
if frickin has arms how do you get to
those I don't know how do you get to the
thrusters I know all God oh I'm sorry
let it settle let it settle
wait mark mark I have an idea ya want it
hold me up and the other one shoot like
a bazooka and see if I'll like launched
into the air
wait you got it
God ready nothing's happening nothing
sad thing is gonna work I got it should
we turn this into Garry's Mod space
program and and try and get someone into
space cuz I think we can do better if I
might we can you know what let's all
take some time we'll do our own thing
I'm gonna go into my own backyard over
here yeah me too me too I was gonna go
help what are you guys
[Music]
you you do your own just everybody here
quietly build to themselves okay and
then we won't have bother anybody else
and then we will be in space in no time
no this is perfect this is perfect this
is gonna it's gonna have yeah
the Rockets have to counterbalance the
subterfuge that sounds right how do I
get to the buttocks part you get a chair
okay
all right you know what it's enough it's
enough messing around that's what this
is strain stool oh my gosh what the
heck's going on here um should I go with
here afterburner big thruster that's
ignored I messed it up you didn't try
hard enough
what button do i press to get the weld
you know it's not a button you press
it's in the tools section and it's got
constraints so you gotta you gotta be
smart about it
yeah it's a big task for you eh but you
got to be smart about it it didn't work
again I think I think I'm not meant for
this job go hell Bob he needs help I'm
busy I'm really busy
no I'm a very kind of God no one come
back here to my backyard
oh crap personal backyard you guys no
need to be around yourself about it I
don't know which backyard Bob's it oh my
god I think I found it
well is it I'm not doing anything crazy
no this is perfectly normal
no it just relax um all right what could
do to help
[ __ ] all I'm spawning is he stupid boxes
where you want it Bob
I always think it just sort of like like
a long here ah my Rockets ready
you guys wanna stop by and give it a try
all right works ready I'm behind the
green and yellow house green roof yellow
I'm standing outside my house come on
back
[Laughter]
okay yeah all right so nice belts on
your